well welcome back to las vegas now so
when it comes to the local housing
market we have seen a lot of changes
especially in the last few months so
here to break it all down for us and
give us the latest updates is jaredy
rain from palacio's realty who is
sponsoring this segment jared thank you
so much for being here thank you so much
for having me of course so i i heard you
are the pro you know everything that
we're talking about today so just the
mouthpiece delivering information so
let's get started a lot of updates are
happening week by week what is today's
update in the market well when i was
here a couple weeks ago
hot cakes were selling like las vegas
homes that sweet fragrance smell is
still lingering in the kitchen but we
hope to have a better recipe for you in
about two weeks 405 thousand that's our
median price point right now we have
rates still in the threes and our
inventory level which we hope to be
better
is creeping up to one month so that's a
good good sign for that for everybody
okay that's good to know that we are
going in the positive and right
direction but with houses over 400k i
mean you can't find anything less now
and the competition is high so is it
even possible to get a house without
going over asking price absolutely it
certainly is in fact here at palacios
realty specifically the five diamond
group we have fantastic records so far
where all of our clients have been able
to pay
with zero over appraised value now
that's a big deal to say in this current
market and so one of the if you're
shopping and you need to stay in budget
four things to keep in mind first be
very very patient it's gonna take a few
weeks to actually get the deal that
you're looking for secondly have a
buyer's consultation it's super
important for you to be able to know
exactly what you want and what you don't
want
and third same thing applies for the
finances know what your limits are and
more importantly
know and be ready to negotiate some of
that cash over praise value because it
might come in handy to be able to win
but most and and really the critical
pieces
don't expect to be number one and to get
your deal accepted first be okay with
second and third because then you can be
a backup offer and then now it's back on
your terms and that's really really
where we've had the winning key for us
yeah that all makes sense and patience
is a virtue and i think it will be worth
it in the long run if we all just know
that it will work out
and so uh i think a lot of us are
thinking though why wouldn't we just
maybe avoid this and and rent what are
your thoughts on that yeah it's a
natural response but the same challenge
we face on the resale side applies on
the on the rental in fact our inventory
for rentals is super super thin uh if
and we expect the rates to go up for the
next couple of years so if you're paying
1600 over 2 000 for a place
why not just own and know what your
payment is for the next 30 years
so it take you know take the heat figure
it out we'll help you with that well
jared this is a lot of helpful
information and i think people are a
little stressed as they're looking to to
buy a house but your advice to them is
just stay calm be patient take the
proper steps and it'll all work out
right absolutely well thank you so much
for sharing all of your knowledge with
us and thank you palacios realty for
sponsoring this segment you can call
them at 702-333-6666
and they have a special offer for you
buy and sell with palacios realty and
you can get a sweet two percent towards
your purchase